[Music]
hey folks welcome back to the Dark Horse
podcast live stream
155 q a segment last thing we're doing
this year on the Dark Horse channel
before we start drinking before we start
drinking which we are gonna do because
it's New Year's Eve this is not vodka no
no it is not
well
or Jim
right it's really pretty much just water
yeah yeah
um am I correct that we do not have a
Discord question yes we don't have a
Discord question uh I don't I in the
past when I have not had one or I've
missed it somehow I've said things like
okay if you send it now I'll get it and
then I forget and it's sort of obnoxious
so I'm not going to claim that I will
see it but if uh someone with access to
the question that uh you guys might have
voted on the Discord server uh sees this
in real time and sends me an email
um in the next 45 minutes or so then uh
we will I've made check and we'll try to
get to it maybe you can help me remember
to check possible we've just answered
all their questions
that would be too bad no it would be too
bad now yeah generate more curiosity
right exactly yes a double dose even
yeah why not I mean sure
[Music]
what's the worst that could happen all
right I couldn't even say it I haven't
heard anybody say that in a while I
think I couldn't I and you still haven't
because I couldn't say to you we're
headed that direction my tongue was like
nope not gonna no don't go there because
we've seen not even the worst that can
happen we don't know we now know that we
don't know the words we can't even
estimate the worst that can happen we
now know that we don't know all right
here we are let us begin answering
questions at darkhorsemissions.com where
you can continue to ask questions
this question
looks like it was asked before we got to
the section on the main podcast so let's
ask it but I think I think we've already
done it all right I've forgotten how to
act with the like hard surfaces in an
actual mic in front of me it's so much
better though
uh new data indicate that the shot flips
inflammatory igg3 antibodies to
non-inflammatory igg4 type which may
cause immune system to ignore covid-19
in the vaxxed
Could lack of selective pressure Drive
Copa 19 to stop mutating
so the second part of that first comment
um seems like the wrong conclusion to me
which may cause immune system to ignore
covid-19 in the vast
well I mean I agree that that's part of
the implication of what may happen if
it's telling me I mean let's take an
example and it's not a perfect example
because it's ige mediated but if you
take a let's say pollen and you react
pollen and you are induced to not react
maybe that's mediated through itt4
then the induced to not react is an igg4
effect potentially okay yeah what I'm
saying is I don't know maybe Nobody
Knows the interaction between the ige
system which is the one that seems to
mediate allergy and the igg4 system
which seems to Tamp down the
inflammatory response now those two
things may be identical and it may match
what I said about immunologists using
the uh
the antigen in question to induce a
um a standing down of the the
inflammatory effect but basic point is
if you have
the igg4
anti-inflammatory effect basically the
anti-immunity signal
then that could cause the immune system
to stop reacting to covet which likely
is a very bad thing right it's the
inverse of what a vaccine is supposed to
do there may be instances in which you
are better off not fighting right so
they're
don't know what the connection is but we
there are certain viruses
that we carry once we've been infected
that hide in tissues and reacting to
them may be a bad thing and basically
once they've invaded let's say
neurological tissue and how they've hid
there it may be best to leave them alone
that may be less damaged now in the case
of covid
the mechanism of action and I as far as
we know it doesn't seem to hide in in
places like immunological tissue
in all likelihood
tamping down the immune response to the
pathogen is inherently bad
if
we Tamp down with these so-called
vaccines the immune response to a
particular Spike motif
it may be that a different immunity
arises that the vaccinated will react as
naive
that they will then have infections that
will precipitate a new immune response
to some other Motif you know to the
nucleocapsid for example
Motif is a term of art here or you're
just you're using that uh it's a term of
art okay so Latif being some
recognizable piece of the virus right
uh now I will point out something I
didn't mention in the in the main
discussion of this which probably
we should have discussed is that there
is now a distinction in light of this
IGG for
uh result
there is now apparently a distinction
between those of us who haven't been
inoculated at all with the MRNA stuff
which presumably also includes people
who got the DNA version the
adenovectored version and those who got
the MRNA version exclusively right so
I don't know how that plays out but the
idea that there will be two populations
one of which has you know those of us
who weren't vaccinated at all against
covid presumably have a much broader
response the natural immunity is not
only stronger but broader it's to
multiple motifs and
then we will have a population in which
or it has the capacity to be broader
right I mean you don't
you get exposed to what for you is a
novel pathogen uh whatever Motif it's
not a term I'd heard before in this
context whatever Motif is first
recognized by immune system will be the
motif that your immune system uh mounts
a response to First and most strongly
and so your immune system will not
necessarily mount a response to all of
the things it's just it it it is more
haphazard with regard to oh it could be
I don't remember the example you just
gave you know if it's not the spike
protein it's something else nuclear
capsid okay
um and you know given that most of the
vaccines seem to be Spike protein
specific yeah
um that that gives the potential for a
person with natural immunity to have
developed immunity
um that will remain robust even if the
spike protein evolves into something
otherwise unrecognizable
well
it's hard to say I mean in a natural
infection there are all kinds of
mechanisms to cause a diversity in the
immune response so for example you have
antigen presenting cells that will take
various different antigens and show them
to the immune system so that there's
sort of a built-in tendency not to hone
in on a single motif
um the question here is
if igg4 is a signal to stand down
then a virus that displays
the
correct electromagnetic signature to
trigger that elevated igg4 response is
sending out a do not it's like a
transponder on a friendly vehicle that
will keep you from targeting it right if
the tank is putting out a signature that
you can recognize that's one of ours
don't shoot at it so if if first stars
cov2 is broadcasting a signal that our
immune system has taken to be a sign not
to shoot
that will give SARS kovi to added leeway
and people who have that uh that igg4
triggering
um it could extend to the other motifs
in other words if the virus is putting
out a signal that tells the immune
system to stand down then does that
basically cloak the other motifs from a
reaction don't know
there does seem to be the potential here
for
two different populations
and I would say human populations yeah
those of us who did not get the vaccines
many of us have had covid
um will have natural immunity from that
interaction
and will not have elevated igt4 yep um
and then there will be those so in other
words you could see a
uh you could see a lot of things
happening a the population of people who
are now
showing elevated levels of igt4 may
allow pathogens to circulate that would
otherwise shut themselves down that
would have and are not below one which
would mean that they tend towards
Extinction but it may circulate and that
may give the opportunity for something
to evolve the ability to get to the
unvaccinated or the less vaccinated
or the DNA vaccinated who are apparently
not having elevated igg4 so again it's a
classic welcome to complex systems yeah
we don't know how this plays out but the
fact that it's like
two human populations those with the
elevated igg4 that will have two
different responses to not only SARS
cov2 but whatever other virus can figure
out a motif to trigger that shutdown
right but the second part of the
question Could lack of selective
pressure Drive Copa 19 to stop mutating
SARS Kobe 2 to stop mutating it
there's there's no lack of selective
pressure there may be a diminishment in
some domains you know in in the motif of
the spike protein in those who are most
RNA mRNA vaccinated well it depends my
guess would be the stand down signal
that is mediated through igg4 could
result in
increase viral proliferation in those
who have that effect and therefore
decreased selective pressure I could see
that
oh
because there's just more of it and so
those people but but that hinges on
there's a there's an assumption in there
which is that that such people would be
more infectious
um
because just producing more
that hasn't doesn't have many mutations
or any within the individual doesn't
meet doesn't have any evolutionary
effect unless it then goes out into the
world and and right so you could have a
difference uh in the
um the sickness within an individual
that doesn't result in it passing on but
my guess is what you've got is you know
the more virus that's affecting greater
numbers of cells effectively constitutes
a larger laboratory in which this gain
of function experiment uh exists so
anyway I think it's frightening no
matter what category you're in yeah
um
but uh
something else I want to say I did want
to say one other thing
about this question of inflammatory and
anti-inflammatory response oh yeah can I
actually read so I had this question
um for you and we didn't get to it in
the top of the hour uh let me just read
from the abstract right uh this is again
if you want to show my screen you can
Zach this is the paper we talked about
in the main episode today uh live stream
155
uh by ear gang at all class switch
towards non-inflammatory Spike specific
IGG for antibodies after repeated Stars
Kobe 2 mRNA vaccinations titled the
paper
second
sentence of the abstract reads shortly
after the initial two mRNA vaccine doses
the IGG response mainly consists of the
pro-inflammatory subclasses igg-1 and
igg3
here we report that several months after
the second vaccination SARS cov2
specific antibodies were increasingly
composed of non-inflammatory igg4 which
were further boosted by a third mRNA
vaccination and or SARS cov2 variant
breakthrough infections
so my question reading that was why does
it why is inflammatory igg-1 and igg3
being inflammatory pro-inflammatory
versus igg4 which is now taking a much
larger chunk than it had previously of
your total IGG complement after all
these mRNA vaccinations which is not
inflammatory
why does that matter what's the
relevance so it is often confusing
there's certain things like inflammation
which we as patients of Medicine
considered negative right inflammation
is bad well inflammation is bad in a
sense but inflammation is also adaptive
right right so what we're looking at is
a system in which inflammation is a
mechanism of action for a response to in
this case a pathogen right so for
example you might get if you have an
infected tissue
that tissue might swell right and it
will swell and produce pus what is pus
pus is white blood cells right and so
when you've got pus in an infected
something what you've got are white
blood cells and antibodies that have
gummed up the something maybe it's a
bacterium
and you know is it good to have pus well
pus is the product of an active immune
response and so anyway there are various
um
Cascades that involve inflammation to
actually recruit immune cells into a
location where they need to do their
action and so medicine often treats
things like inflammation and the answer
is sometimes that's likely to be
counterproductive right just I mean
treating all sorts of symptoms so you
know oh I'm uncomfortable doctor well
let me see what I can do to make you
comfortable how about we get rid of the
reason I'm uncomfortable as opposed to
getting rid of the discomfort treating
fevers is the same thing very often not
always but very often exactly and so you
know people will also be familiar
antihistamines are considered good
because they shut down an allergic
response but the point is the allergic
response is the inappropriate action of
the immune system and the histamine
response is part of a correct immune
response to an infection right so
there's a histamine Cascade and
antihistamine Works assuming that what
you've got is an allergic response that
you do want to shut down you know and
out of place allergic response rather
than a correctly placed immunological
response to a pathogen yeah so anyway
it's that inflammation is part of a
proper response it certainly goes wrong
but medicine
often over interprets it because it's
present where there is pathology but
often as a response to it
good
all right before we get to the next
question could I get uzac to just put
something over the light that's coming
off the computer the flashy stroby thing
that I'm um
that is now with our new setup in my
line of sight
because I don't want to have like a
seizure on camera I don't have seizures
but
yeah I don't want to right yeah I think
not wanting to is perfectly valid
totally I forgot what to do I forgot to
do this there we go that's the one we
just read right yeah okay
um
is there an evolutionary take on why
humans tend to ReDiscover the past
rediscovery of classical Antiquity
rediscovery of authentic Baroque musical
practices in the past several decades
recycling of fashion trends and it's
written by someone who uh who's
screen name is Daniel kergenov violinist
um
I mean I'm happy to to Riff on this I
think it's probably not a single thing
yeah but
a
the way Evolution Works forget humans
forget rediscovery of the past but the
way Evolution works is
something will generate a new set of
opportunities right we talked last time
about for example the amnion the
membrane that allows eggs to be freed
from a liquid environment
um but one of four okay a membrane that
allows eggs to be freed from a liquid
environment that opens up a whole range
of possibilities for creatures to
exploit niches
that are not right next to water right
so that causes what we call an adaptive
radiation right that is a radiation of a
bunch of different forms that try
different stuff and over time what
happens is that
radiation of branches gets pruned of
stuff that worked sort of but wasn't
stable long term right and it may be
that a bunch of little branches go
extinct and some of the branches that
did really well then pick up the niche
space that represented the branches that
have gone extinct something like that
but what you see
is a large number of experiments that
then gets narrowed down over time so one
thing you might imagine in human art
space for example is that somebody
figures out
you know an instrument that allows you
to explore some part of musical space
that wasn't accessible with whatever you
had before right and that results in a
whole lot of experimentation some of it
is interesting momentarily but doesn't
go anywhere and some of it's really good
and opens up whole new genres and so you
might imagine that there would be a kind
of return to the well phenomenon right
that basically you know you have some
set of standards and then you have
experimentation the experimentation is
the fun place to be until it's not
anymore and then returning to the well
and figuring out where the next
radiation goes is better than trying to
create the next radiation from the tip
of a branch or something like that
so there's that I think there's also in
human space
the and this is sort of it's It's
classic in terms of what we were talking
about with respect to conservatism and
progressivism
um earlier today which is
progressivism is where the dynamism
comes from but it's dangerous right
progressivism goes wrong a lot right you
can't say well then screw progressivism
because then you don't get anywhere you
have to have the progressivism but the
point is the progress the idea that the
progressives go crazy might be kind of a
an evergreen right right the tension
between the two and the the constant you
know battle from both sides to get more
of what they think is right which is to
say change in one hand and not change in
the other
that that is necessary because you take
one of those away and suddenly you're
just stuck or you're moving fast and
without any intervaling Force you're not
going to be in good shape after very
long right because stuck stuck in a
totally static world if what if it had
been working might be okay if everyone
agreed that it was awesome and but but
that's welcome to complex systems times
a thousand here right so uh there is no
ability to say well what we had was
perfect and it remains perfect and
nothing has changed and therefore that's
what we need to to to maintain that
across all systems but of course there
will be domains of which that may be
true like actually and all of the
proposed changes are too dangerous too
unknown to fraught so we're going to
stick with what you got for now until we
know more about possible changes at
least and there is also the added
problem that when things go wrong you
may not know where the wrong turn was
you may be able to detect I mean we are
in the circumstance right every
institution has failed people are
believing absolute gobbledygook but the
question is all right if you wanted to
reboot from a prior state
what's the last state that worked yeah
we're not going to agree on that right
and so I think we are seeing a strange
but maybe not so strange resurgence
of a conservatism deeper than most of us
would have expected to return right
we're seeing a Resurgence of
um religious belief
that is more
Fundamentalist
than you might expect in a very modern
age like this one and in some sense I
think the message is yeah but you got
screwed up right the last thing that
worked you know was closer to those old
stories yeah
um so anyway it will be interesting to
see how that plays out I think there's a
danger in that too because I don't
actually of course there is you can't
not only is it
um
it is unlikely to work right returning
to the world of Yahweh and Jesus
it doesn't answer the questions of today
so it's even the fat even if it is the
last place that things worked it's not
relevant to most of the stuff that we
actually now need to manage
yeah well I mean
you could argue
said I as about as far from being a
Biblical scholar as you can you can get
I read it but it's been a while right
um you could argue that you need those
as you need some of the teachings
therein uh at least in the New Testament
in order to be foundational things about
which we can agree
but that that is only a start and that
it is nowhere near that it you I could
see an argument for and I'm not sure I'm
making this argument myself but I could
see an argument for them being necessary
but not sufficient uh to move forward
with uh care in the world and trying to
form a society that is
maximally uh able to uh to generate
well-being for the maximum number of
people as possible
yeah
um
I think I think we're in trouble because
I think the instinct to reboot from
something fundamental
is kicking in and I think
well I didn't make an argument for
reboot that wasn't anything that I said
I know but you said necessary but not
sufficient
and my point would be even I also said
that that wasn't my argument that I
might believe that but that I could see
a I could see that argument being made
yeah well I think the problem is
as you as we argue in our book
you can't go back we have to go forward
and there's no safe way to do that and
um I think that's just where we're stuck
it's really right but I I mean I I'm not
sure what you're disagreeing with and
what I said that uh the I mean this this
is a point that I feel like you've made
that there is much in specifically the
teachings in the New Testament that hold
value in today's world and it is turning
away from them uh that has in part led
to some of the decay of other functional
systems right so I guess what I'm what
I'm arguing now and I don't mean to be
disagreeing with anything that you're
saying I don't think I do but
you have two things have gone wrong
only two two fundamental things okay
wrong one we've lost our minds in some
kind of a progressive way right where
there's no discipline in progressivism
anymore and change is good
I'll change is good or change everything
that we have is bad tear it down
something better will happen all that
nonsense
the instinct when that happens is a
reboot but in the period since the last
reboot
everything fundamental has changed right
when are you calling the last reboot I
don't know I don't know I don't think it
matters I think the point is the rate of
change is so fast that whatever the last
place where there was an outbreak of
conservatism that restored some kind of
mental discipline that allowed us to
move forward again last time that
happened it was a whole different world
and so I don't think
I don't see an answer I don't yet hear
you said that we had two problems and
you said you know progressivism yeah you
know so what so the the issue on the the
conservative side the side on the right
whatever whatever we should be calling
it
the issue is is how what is that in a
nutshell if the problem over here in
terms of like how progressivism is going
off the rails is if changes if change is
often good
the illogic goes then all change must be
good and we must embrace all change or
else you're a fascist right wow so that
you know that's that's easy to describe
and we've done it so what's what's the
version like imagine that we
set off into space in a fit of
wide-eyed progressivism okay we're
traveling in space and then at some
point
the space progressivists lose the plot
and they start following dark energy to
the next great human location and it
turns out not to be true it doesn't lead
us anywhere and we're starving and all
of that okay and the answer is well
let's go back to the last place that
worked good idea except it blew up
it's not there anymore so you can't go
back to it and that's what I'm arguing
has happened is that the world in which
the conservatives in which their point
applies
doesn't exist
okay but and they don't know that the
Golden Rule yeah it's not it has not
blown up no the Golden Rule and this
this has been my argument with with
Jordan Peterson is there are a few
things that are timeless
right Golden Rule being a real good
example and you know the fact that the
golden rule is a
um one of many versions of that rule and
various different Traditions tells us
that that one's probably pretty robust
but the point is that's you can't live
on the golden we can't eat it
right
um so
the idea that there's you know that
there's some group of Amish who remember
the old ways and can show us how to do
that again
the old way is
don't answer how you live at a
population in which you know more than
half of us are the product of the
neighborhood process right but if I'm
not just you got to exactly what I was
going to say and I we top of the hour
last hour whatever hours ago now
um we were talking about organic farming
practices yep and you know we
choose can afford to and choose to eat
in a way that everyone on the planet
can't yep right so that's not
sustainable if we try to apply our
values and conclusions for ourself to
everyone you know equitably right we
just it won't you know each scale it
doesn't scale so you know the Haber
Bosch process which uh fixes nitrogen
without having to use legumes to do it
basically and so allows for a lot more
food to be grown which is invented in
the early 20th century
um facilitated a population boom uh
which I don't I don't know what else
would have done it right like you know
we don't we the history didn't run that
way but it's really hard to imagine what
other thing could have caused the
population to Boom quite so
extravagantly yep as
um as as the Hebrew Bosch process
but that's not
an argument against you know organic
farming that's not an argument against
you know so the fact that you can't it
doesn't work for everyone
if you're going to make that argument
there then you have to make it to a
number of the choices that that we're
making elsewhere as well to be
consistent but let's let's take the
Amish as an example okay the Amish are a
great
uh test case of preserving the old ways
right very conscious very consciously
preserve the old ways and stepped off
the escalator of progressivism
if you say well
the Amish function and you try to return
to it then
three four billion people are gonna
starve almost immediately
so that can't be a solution we have to
go somewhere that
um presupposes the Haber Bosch process
and weans us away from its bad
consequences this is one of the problems
I think for for Elon Musk actually right
because musk is
correctly distrustful of the
depopulation Instinct that so many
progressives Express and his point is
actually no we can have more people we
can do it well and it's not that he
doesn't have a point I mean you know he
is the electric car guy right
um he's also
pruning Cobalt from their process you
know he is farsighted
but
a I think Mars Loom's too large
in his thinking and the point is I mean
if that's not cornucopianism I don't
know what is
I don't want to call it cornucopianism
because he's super mechanistic about all
this stuff it's not like he doesn't know
what it means to make Mars habitable
right but mechanistic is reductionist
right like you know he's
you can count up all the stuff that you
know you need to sustain actual life at
the most
basic level and that doesn't tell you
that quality of life will be anything
close to anything that any human being
is going to be able to to deal with as
you know I know I know I think I think
Mars is a laughable solution to this
problem and not because he's
mechanistically wrong about the
possibility I think he might be wrong
about time scale but I'm willing to even
defer to him it's not it's not the most
important question it's not the most
important question the most important
question oddly is at what point does
Mars become a better answer than
stabilizing the earth and the answer is
pretty much never in the foreseeable
future yeah
um so
that said
we are now in a pickle there are too
many people to live this way on this
planet there are ways you could alter
how we live here and you could even do
it well that would allow more people but
what you can't do is you can't have a
system in which the growth in population
is built in
right you could have a stable High
number you could have a stable loan
number which you can't have is the
expectation of more and more people all
the time all right that is
self-destabilizing and I you know I have
not heard him speak deeply enough about
this to know presumably he gets that but
what I hear is mostly his correct
challenge to those who say depopulate
um but I don't hear enough to know what
the alternative plan is and I hear too
much of Mars which strikes me as a kind
of
it's a Hail Mary pass at surviving what
seems to be coming
but it's not nearly as good as averting
the disaster down here on Earth while
it's still preservable
yep I'm not sure how we got onto Elon
Musk
um he's a space Progressive of a
interesting kind
of thing okay next question
somehow I think we've answered two
questions and it's like 40 minutes in
um this one is written in slightly
concise style so I'm going to try to
interpret it uh gato John Taylor Gatto
said
I think this is a representation of
gato's view on Darwin and Wallace I will
say before I read the question and try
to make sense of exactly what it says
that
um gato's take on Evolution at least as
he understands it as as it has been
taught in schools is the one place where
I have discovered that I completely
disagree with him that I think that gato
has fallen prey to the thing that so
many social scientists I don't think
gato called himself a social scientist
but um I have I've interacted with so
many social scientists anthropologists
sociologists that sort of thing who
think that Darwin is evil and therefore
thinking evolutionarily is evil because
of the way that either they learned what
it was or the the things that have been
done in its name
and this is a just as a simple logical
fallacy
um but at least in so far and I haven't
read all of gato's books but I've read a
fair bit and I love him overall in terms
of educational thinking and Theory
um but I think he does fall prey I think
he's just he just never he can't anymore
he's dead now
um but he just never had anyone who
actually understood what evolution was
or just sit down and be like no this is
actually what it is so it's possible
that this question suggests that he did
because what it says is gato
colon Darwin versus Wallace was
political
school's got
biological Advance via deadly
competition rather than adaptation and
cooperation or primary
do you agree
so I don't get the Darwin versus Wallace
here because Darwin Darwin and Wallace
weren't like competition versus
cooperation neither of them particularly
put one of those before the other if I
understand the question correctly and I
don't remember seeing this in inigato
that I've read
it sounds like we are being told that
gato said
uh that the version of evolution that
was being taught in schools was
competition driven as opposed to
cooperation driven
um I don't agree with the combining
cooperation with adaptation and that
doesn't make any sense adaptation is
equal you know cooperation competition
are equally adaptive
um so take that out of this picture here
for a moment and I don't understand the
Darwin versus Wallace thing either
because yeah I think it's almost uh
their background as people yeah yeah
okay so but take that out too I don't
know if that's a misunderstanding if
that's just the way the question is
worded misunderstanding I've got to like
I don't know where that is but if we
take it to how I think what this means
is
um and maybe this is a match for what I
uh
what I have seen as an error in gato's
thinking on Evolution
um he we are told argued yeah well
Evolution was taught as as competition
for reasons that have nothing to do with
reality and if we just gone down a
different path then we would have been
um studying cooperation just as much and
I'm reminded of this crazy thing that we
experience in grad school which uh you
know better than I do and maybe you
should report on yeah this is this is a
a recurrent theme amongst
um
good-hearted but wrong-headed biologists
well and other people right it's
contagious because it's a very
attractive story yeah right you know
capitalists who blah blah blah blah blah
Evolution blah blah blah blah blah over
focused on competition and haven't
realized the glory of cooperation yada
yada and so you know what we encountered
in the worst case was ecologists who I
would argue
is a group of biologists overwhelmingly
motivated to go into biology by the
desire to do good which gets in the way
of their ability to understand what's
going on they're very often I mean
ecology is fascinating but your ability
to leverage what you learn is often
minimal and if they studied it as a
basic science rather than how are we
going to fix stuff science they'd be
better at it but anyway we encountered
ecologist counting instances in which
the evolution textbooks reported on
something competitive and compared to
the number of times that cooperation was
mentioned and then because the number
was wildly in favor of competition
decided that these books were obviously
biased by their capitalists blah blah
blah blah blah well it is the same
freaking error frankly as oh my god
there are more male software Engineers
than female software Engineers therefore
there is bias against female software
engineers yes or
or you shouldn't expect a one-to-one
ratio because in the case of software
Engineers maybe men are more predisposed
to be interested in software engineering
having nothing to do with whether or not
they are handed computers as children
although that helps
and maybe and actually this is 100 True
competition exists in nature a lot and
so does cooperation but competition
probably more frequent but it's
definitely easier to find and measure
well I'll go one step farther what got
me in trouble when I first heard this
business about counting in textbooks I
did that's what you did at or and I
raised my hand and I remember the cranes
necks and the dirty looks and all of
that but anyway but they were ecologists
you could probably run faster than that
absolutely
um
not nice and actually many of the
ecologists very dedicated and field work
I'm sure they've no it's fine out there
but
um but anyway the what I said we have a
colleges among some of our closest
friends am I allowed to say that I think
you are uh what I said to them as a sort
of uh visitor across the aisle from
Evolution into ecology which has always
been kind of a fraught border but
anyway I was interested in the college
because I was interested in the subject
matter what I said to them was look
competition is inherent to an ecosystem
you there is no way you could construct
an ecosystem in which competition would
not be dominant you can construct an
ecosystem without cooperation won't be
very interesting cooperation will evolve
but the basic point I mean look it'll
it'll be out competed by a more
Cooperative ecosystem oh boy right so
here's here's the punch line to the joke
the punch line is hey guess what
ecologists
why do you think we cooperate
we cooperate to compete that's why it is
a mode of competition and the point is
it is a more effective mode of
competition when it is possible but it
is not a as many things are yeah more
effective when they're possible
more effective when they're possible
absolutely but it is not a an argument
against competition as an argument event
for competing more effectively against
whoever it is you're competing against
and
um so you know we can't all just get
along no it's not you know it's it's not
going to be possible for everyone you
know
equity for everyone including everything
in the universe like no that's not how
it works no you have you would have to
architect a system to to frustrate the
competition because the competition is
utterly basic and that wouldn't be
stable it wouldn't last right so think
about it this way if you have a habitat
and there's more stuff in it than the
creatures in it can use than the number
of creatures goes up until that's not
true that's the first argument
um
and so what that means is to the extent
that you have a circumstance in which
there's no competition it will evolve to
a competitive circumstance but even
worse
imagine
if you've got a habitat that's got a
thousand times as much Resource as the
creatures in it need and it's heading
towards carrying capacity where we'll
have the amount of resource that that
number of creatures needs there is also
a competition to fill it up first right
so the competition is there from the
first hour right even if it doesn't look
like it
um and so anyway yeah if God if this is
a representation of godo's view he's got
it wrong as do all of the other people
who have made this argument as do the
group selection of sumac similar
arguments and anyone else
um you know I think that's a pretty good
list for today for 2022 I think that's
about enough okay we'll stop there
excellent
I rarely ever got sick before but since
recovering from covid last year I've had
three major bouts of fever each lasting
about a week anyone else experience a
similar trend
I haven't heard this but I'm interested
if other people
have so
the pattern is
we really got sick before since
recovering from covid has has been sick
three times
um for a week each seems to be getting
more sick more frequently and this is of
course predicted by some of what we're
talking about like
um on the igg4 result
um anecdotally
none of us have experienced that and I
haven't heard it but that's right but I
would say one of the weird signatures of
this particular virus
is the number of different things that
seems to disrupt it doesn't disrupt them
in everybody and it will depend on where
you got like where you were sick with it
even though it will manifest you know
inosmia the loss of smell and taste
seems to be pretty common right I
experienced it
um but uh the first tissue were tissues
that it lodged May well predict
um you know what kind of progressive
disease what kind of progressive disease
and what kind of susceptibility to other
disease you have downstairs right I mean
and the basic there's a deeper message
here which is
we tend to think our arm the model that
we are all running on about getting sick
you know getting a cold getting better
getting the flu getting better
um is way oversimplified
the fact is disease does damage
and damage has consequences damage
basically accelerates the Aging of
whatever tissues were damaged and so you
are a composite of tissues that are a
different meaningful Age based on where
you've been damaged and by what and I
would say
covid does damage to a lot of stuff it's
different what it damages in different
people and based on how you got it
but the answer is you're probably not as
better as you think right you were
probably made vulnerable I mean just
think for example about
um
a tissue that has lost cells to your own
immune system killing them because they
were infected with covet those wounds
are now vulnerabilities for an unrelated
pathogen to exploit well I wonder
actually if this might not be one of the
things
that is meant by long coveted
right that long covet is clearly kind of
a junk category right there's a lot of
people you know some people are
hypochondriacs some people are really
sick with covety symptoms for a long
time and there's everything in between
and uh to the degree that covet hits you
know gets into a tissue that actually
you know will not recover completely
will leave you more susceptible uh you
know even if the person writing this
question does not feel sick in between
the bouts that might you know if if
there is greater susceptibility there
because of what kovid did that is at the
very least a downstream effective covid
and you know what is Downstream
effective covet if not long coven yep
um I will say that there are good
doctors who are treating both long
coveted and vaccine injuries and if you
have one of these things seek them out
they they are not hard to find
um you know
follow the podcasts to the doctors who
have been proven right by their
courageous stand and reach out to them
they they figured out how to treat these
things and anyway I know a number of
examples of people who have greatly
benefited after waiting a long time
finally seek out treatment and uh are
glad they did yep okay let's um we're
closing in on an hour actually I think
um but we've only answered a few
questions so let's try to get some of
these are just comments really we will
try to get through them quickly Dr Drew
is interviewing kova dissenters also
says he's known fauci for decades but
may have been name dropping seems able
to think evolutionarily maybe worth an
interview
all right
what is your stance on pet dog and cat
vaccinations especially if you're living
in the country with limited exposure to
other domestic animals
one thing for sure one thing I'll say
for sure
is
um and this is I've talked about this
before uh that it was actually we were
well into covid and I took our our black
cat Tesla was having some issues and I
took him to a holistic vet and one of
the things the holistic vet said which
should have been obvious to me from
years ago and it hadn't occurred to me
or to us was this was at that point a
nine-year-old cat he's 11 and a half now
uh and he said he's as vaccinated as he
needs to get we had been we had gotten
him fully vaxed and he was getting his
yearly boosters of everything and this
vet said to me
why so I don't know because I'm being
told to
um and he said you know what what in
your life do you have to get that level
of boosters up and of course this is
this was I think the summer of 2020 was
before the code vaccines are out and I
like many people who are otherwise
enthusiastic about vaccines we're not so
enthusiastic about the flu vaccine
because it just didn't seem very well I
don't know at least effective and I
don't know about safe so um it's like
putting that aside which is clearly
acting somewhat differently he said you
know you don't need a tetanus vaccine
every year you don't like you don't the
stuff that you've been vaccinated
against you don't eat every year so why
should your cat
um and so that that at least right uh
that the schedule who I don't know who
writes the schedule for veterinary
vaccines but the schedule seems to be
built for profit rather than for animal
health and safety and that may actually
contribute to why so many especially
older and animals are experiencing so
much inability to tolerate food that
they could once tolerate
yeah I would say
how could it be otherwise yeah right you
have a system in which there's
effectively no liability because you're
talking about a pet and so the amount
that you know
if you kill a person you're talking
about potentially millions in losses if
you kill a pet you're talking about
trivial amounts so small that nobody
will sue right now okay class action I
know it could happen but nonetheless
in a system where the risk to
companies for producing an unsafe
vaccine
uh are minimal and in a situation where
it's hard to track effects
um it seems to me inevitable that
unnecessary vaccines will be produced
they will end up being pushed by people
with perverse incentives that
unfortunately includes veterinarians who
make money on these things for one thing
if you're your animals do for a vaccine
then you have to bring your animal in
you're going to get your animal seen so
you know yeah there's all kinds of
perverse incentives you probably need to
have their teeth cleaned while they're
in there yeah pay for another visit
and teeth cleaned so I you know
I have lots of concerns and I've
certainly seen animals become allergic
to their food in a way that I don't
remember ever having encountered years
ago so what the hell is going on
um so I would be cautious and I would
say I would as I would with a human I
would treat
different vaccines differently based on
how they are made how long-standing
their use is
and the seriousness of the disease if
they contract it yep and with regard to
limited exposure to other domestic
animals I would just say
um obviously that is relevant and it
should be relevant but pay attention to
which diseases are also transmissible by
wild animals so something like rabies is
obviously not limited to domestic
animals
um FIV I think is limited to cats yep
right and so if your cat if you've got
an indoor outdoor cat and there really
aren't any other cats in the area
um you know that that is a consideration
that you should be including in your
analysis
yep
maybe a raised platform for the furry
friends to Lounge on camera behind you
question mark yeah
yeah I like it
love the new studio setup Happy New Year
to you both and happy New Year to all of
you thank you what talk have you heard
about vaccine shedding Roots besides
through sex and breast milk
and this is sort of what I was trying to
get at before yeah I mean look any any
route is plausible could you breathe out
some component of this sure are you
peeing it out probably
um you know it's got to come out
somewhere maybe it'll be so broken down
that it doesn't matter but anyway I
would just say
um we are in a sufficiently novel
environment with these things that one
should not take anything for granted
yeah
Heather where did you get your wooden
laptop stand is in the one that you use
when on your couch I want one can't find
that model online uh put on my screen
for a minute I found it
I've had it for years but they still
make it and here it is levenger uh
l-e-v-e-n-g-e-r.com and it's actually on
sale right now so yeah levenger is tools
for readers they have lots of lovely and
mostly a little bit too expensive stuff
but this one's on sale right now so uh
there you go there's your answer it's
called The Nantucket bamboo lap reader
although if you go to Lavender and you
just look up laptop stand you'll get
there no bamboo and then the whole thing
is oh
laughs
okay
foreign
a recommendation danger model from Polly
matsinger provides an upgrade of self
non-self
I don't know it okay okay that's a
textbook I think
danger model that doesn't really sound
like a textbook so much but it sounds
like a book all right yeah
uh okay two-part question it looks like
Bruce de mosquito's model
a ruler's interest is to minimize the
number of keys to power
citizens are blocks rewarded if
necessary for keeping power elderly
women blacks Etc woke the woke or
amalgamating blocks peace people of
color and minorities my take is that's
why black Trans lives matter must black
Trans lives must matter over everyone's
own interests
I think there's something game
theoretically Right Here It ultimately
becomes unstable right these coalitions
that are going to gather for the purpose
of mutiny will ultimately tear each
other to Pieces
um they've already indicated an affinity
for Mutiny yes right okay for instance
people who have taken on Mutiny as a
profession are going to end up Mutiny
against each other indeed um it's really
not that hard to predict yes no there's
no they're there and destroying
civilization in order to discover that
there's no there there would be a shame
I say we stop now all right let's do it
okay
okay
um IGG follow-up I thought the study
showed a tamped down response to spike
itself how does that translate to
reduced generalized immunity
it doesn't except that my understanding
at least is that if the variable region
of this antibody this IGG 4 antibody uh
Finds Its Target that it tamps down
immunity and so that means that anything
that can display that flag has the
ability to set to send that trigger
message so
the question is are other respiratory
viruses for example going to end up
evolutionarily exploring space around
that trigger
because the closer they get to it the uh
you know the greater their effectiveness
so anyway it's not General immunity that
will be tamped down but the question is
it may be much broader than SARS cov2
because we're not talking about a motif
so complex that other viruses won't
evolve
all right let's go pen yeah don't take
that
foreign
you're going to make any New Year's
resolutions I have one to recommend to
you just
[Music]
done
actually you've been better about this
later lately in part because I've hidden
them
I I I have a perfect I'll put it I'll
put it within reach and see what happens
fiddling is not stealing though can we
agree on that yeah but I mean you were
fiddling and you you recognizing
yourself that you were that was a deep
deeply morally ingrained revulsion at
the idea of stealing your pen I'll say
You're really tired of having me be on
your case about where all of my pens why
are they all gone again yeah that too
except
I really like these pens they're good
they're really they're good pens yeah
signo uniball 0.38 yeah there it is
just asking to be taken but it's such a
beautifully refined pen that I discussed
myself when I write with it
what because it's just like the past
tense of disgust no no no no I'm
disgusted by my writing because you know
you take a fine input
I can't make a oh a decent looking
sentence with one of those so you
definitely shouldn't steal them then you
should only steal the pendants that give
you an excuse for not having good
writing you're going to have to
eliminate all of the other potential
thieves before you know for sure that
I'm still stealing them we don't ferrets
that's true yeah that's true
oh Tesla okay it might be Tesla yeah he
is he is a bit of a a writer cryptic
writer
uh the new studio lighting is the bomb
if I didn't know better I'd say Heather
is using more makeup than just a little
powder yeah I'm not just doing the same
yeah so apparently Zachary Zachary thank
you yeah yeah
apparently the site and I have caught
Zachary touching the soft boxes he likes
them very much they are such nice lights
yeah yeah now we're pleased we got we
had a lot more to do here but this is
this is good this is good
um is the blind unscientific code
following due to the Milgram experiment
effect
yeah I mean maybe more than that some
that's part of it you know
Edward Bernays on top of the Milgram
effect but yeah
um but at the very least yeah they got
all of the authorities to line up in
their lab coats and tell us to shock the
[ __ ] out of the patient and uh a lot of
people there yeah like okay yeah I'll do
it pretty much that oh it's for their
own good okay
okay
um one more question which um
they want answered badly enough they
wrote in twice with the same question um
how long have you two been married and
how do you both keep things fresh since
you live and work together love your
podcast
who says we keep things fresh
sorry now I'm filling with my own pen
yes and attacking your husband no
um I didn't mean that you know that you
wouldn't have asked the question that
way if you thought that that you were
gonna get
crazy back
um we actually as of tomorrow tomorrow
is the year in which we will have been
married 25 years not tomorrow it's not
our anniversary that's not until August
but I booked it right yes
yeah we were married in 1998 but we were
together longer than that at the point
that we got married it felt like oh yeah
we've been together so long what is it
even right matter yeah yeah
um
traveling helps yes also I mean not
being terrible to one another not being
terrible to one another having a sense
about yourself
um
the fact of having I mean it's non-stop
Adventure even when we don't choose it
right I mean so yeah we definitely have
not chosen
nothing like being
chased out of your career together to
yeah help you see each other in a
positive light yeah but I mean we're
actually remember though so yeah I know
you do whenever green blew up there was
some hope some some of what some of it
was explicitly stated
that I would use this opportunity to
turn on you yep
by people at Evergreen yep yeah and some
of them thought I would right well this
this is a mistake they made across the
board they thought our students would
turn on us they thought you'd turn on me
yep
um and I think I mean it's really a very
sad commentary on what their lives must
be like yeah right are there friendships
and their love relationships and their
Professor student relationships so
thin they're you know they're gonna turn
on a dime on each other and probably but
I guess they turned on us so that tells
us but yeah no it it does and I think
uh I mean I I tried following that
particular logic through it's not it's
not a great thing to focus on for this
question because it's a lovely question
it's big and expansive and there's a lot
of places we could go here but
um I tried
I
tried figuring out if the people who
actually thought that that it was it
wasn't actually even if I were that sort
of even even if I'd been looking for an
excuse yeah to break up our relationship
and our family and this was it
I'm then still at Evergreen
being a professor having seen what
they're willing to do to one of the
other two most popular professors at
Evergreen well you know look you no way
but I do think that they were tapping
into a rule of thumb truth about the
world
most people are dissatisfied with their
lives at one level or another and that
makes them
um viable
right purchasable yeah yeah so the point
is exploring whether there's some deal
you'd be willing to take to turn on your
husband you know it's insane in this
context you get to keep most of the life
that you created with him right in fact
the thing is if you had responded
positively to that invitation
um you could have been a hero duh right
a hero among troglodytes right a hero an
evergreen hero yes right and so the
point is you know as as with our
students right what did we see we saw
our students stand up in shock and
horror at what was being done because it
didn't make any sense to them but to
those because they were awesome right
because you had an actual relationship
with them as we have an actual
relationship with one another
and
but you can imagine I mean a I I don't
wanna
to our own horns as it were but at some
level you can imagine how many
professors can you go after in that way
and not have anybody take the deal
right
you don't have a disgruntled student in
your class who's looking for an excuse
to say yes racist well we didn't nope
right so
um yeah and as much as the the deafening
Silence from almost all of our
colleagues was in fact a deafening and
destructive and eye-opening
no one stood up and said yeah but I mean
and there there was one hateful person
who keeps trying over and over again and
um she's just so perilously incompetent
uh that no one takes her seriously but
not a a supposed colleague not a student
yeah but but I think the thing is most
people
there's a lot of opportunity to corrupt
people because what they have isn't so
good that they wouldn't accept a better
offer and I think what you're pointing
to is
um
weird and paradoxical in light of the
fact that what we were doing was real
and
our lives were real and so
you know it fell on deaf ears but yeah I
can imagine that Ploy working in other
contexts with different people
yeah I think so and
well there's there's a lot more there's
a lot more to go with here but I think
um
feel free to ask the question again if
you like and we'll riff again
um maybe that's maybe that's good for
now a good way a good way to end 2022.
for Dark Horse I think
hell yeah don't you think all right uh
we are now
eight hours from the new year
here at Dark Horse and the vast majority
of you have got to be closer if not it's
already tomorrow it's already 20 23.
it's already 20 23. okay well how's it
going yeah how is it awesome I hope so
is it is it safe and effective
until we see you next be good to the
ones you love eat good food and get
outside Happy New Year
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]